working towards long terms achievements can be mentally
and physically exhausting
it can be a let down to work towards a goal
and not see results as quickly as you were hoping for
but if you work smart, achieving your goal is possible
no matter your goals
here at phych2go we have 7 tips to help you achieve that
1: write your goals down
even if you know what you want
actually write down your goals has proven to be more effective
make sure that it is visible
so you will have a continue reminder of what you set up to achieve
try putting a note on your bathroom mirror, or your fridge
so you will see it every day
2: be patient with yourself
Rome wasn't built in a day
and reaching your goals wont necessarily happen super fast
it would likely take hours and hours of hardwork
the best things in life often take time
and that makes them more awarding
3: make time in your week for goals
instead of trying to rush through your projects
all yourself an hour a day or a day a week to work on
small sub-goals that will contribute to your overall vision
doing things weekly in small segments
will help prevent you from feeling
stuck or frustrated in your attempt to achieve your goal
4: celebrate our achievements no matter how small
sometime it can feel like it is so far from reaching a milestone
and you are not any closer then when you started
but if you are actively working towards something
that's not true
remember these goals are called long term for a reason
find a way to reward yourself
with your favorite snack or activity when you finish a part of your goal
5: remember that roadblocks are't failures
we all know the phrase when one door closes
another door opens
well it is not just inspiring, it is factual
sometimes life has a different on how we achieve our goals
so next time you hit a wall, remember to be kind to yourself
you'll never know what could be around the coner
6: listen to criticism
and do not take them personally
criticisms are not personal attacks on your works
they aren't a chance for you to get defensive
and possessive of your work and goals
instead, take the criticism and use it to  refine and improve upon your goal
and the methods of getting there
criticisms allow us to double check our works with new eyes
and create something even more amazing
7: work with like minded people
this is an especially important tip
because it is easier to feel alone when you are in debbers
there are also other times when you will feel stuck in your efforts
to figure out solutions to the things that sat between you and your achievements
talking and collaborating with those that share similar goals
is actually a great way to see things in a different way
get inspired and maintain drive
climbing the mountain of success is
is always easier when your are working as a team
subtitles..........Me